Thanksgiving is if it weren't for the  importance of Christmas it would be my  favorite holiday it's wonderful and for  deep reasons in my opinion Thanksgiving  comes in the autumn and it comes when  the harvest is in the thing that you  harvest grows of its own accord and you  can't make that happen and so there was  this movement that the nation should be  grateful and atone at the end of each  harvest each productive year you have to  remember until in the middle of the 20th  century most everybody was a farmer and  so those things that I just said were in  the bones of everybody so the nation  should be grateful  isn't that lovely freedom is a blessing  learning is a blessing constitutional  government is a blessing we should be  apologetic we should be regretful when  we fail to count those blessings and  live up to them and we should say so to  God and we should thank him for the  existence of those blessings and our  chance to pursue them  not bad for Thanksgiving